- [Narrator] This is a
Bitcoin mine hidden deep
in the mountains of Sichuan in China.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] And its rival
is on the other side of the planet
at a former factory
that used to make denim for Levi's.
- You see the transformers
lined up on the outside.
We have a lot of megawatts.
- These two miners make money
by providing the massive computing power
that's required to process
and record a high volume of
cryptocurrency transactions.
Business was soaring as Bitcoin
hit new highs in early 2021.
- It's hard to sleep.
You go to bed at night and
you wake up and you look
and you go, "Holy crap, it's still up.
- [Narrator] Last year,
China controlled 70%
of the global processing power
that runs the Bitcoin network
and that means the majority
of the cryptocurrency's
global transactions
are routed through
these computers in China
and recorded by miners here.
So a group of US miners
is raising hundreds
of millions of dollars
to win a larger share
of Bitcoin's processing power.
- When capitalism in the
States decides it wants
to get into market, get into an industry,
it moves heavy capital there.
- [Narrator] They say
their work is also meant
to protect Bitcoin.
Industry insiders say
the Chinese government
has already cracked down on
some crypto entrepreneurs
and could potentially
disrupt global trading
by asking miners in China
to block certain users
from making transactions.
- It's better for
cryptocurrency to be spread
around the globe.
So that Bitcoin cannot be manipulated
by any single government.
- I think there will be competition.
There's more and more human resources,
technology resources that we're putting
into this particular new segment.
- [Narrator] The battle
over Bitcoin mining
will decide who controls
the infrastructure
that powers the cryptocurrency.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Yulong Liu started mining
during the previous Bitcoin rally in 2017.
And this is one of the sites he works with
that has mined about 8,000 Bitcoins
over the past three years,
generating about $28 million in revenue
over that time period.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Miners
need cheap electricity,
which is abundant in some
parts of China thanks
to dams and coal power plants
that were built by the
state in the past decade.
That electricity then powers fast machines
that are necessary to
solve mathematical problems
in order to eventually mint new coins.
China is home to the vast majority
of mining equipment production
and so miners like Liu
always have speedy access
to the best technology,
like this cooling system.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] But the
industry in China lives
with uncertainty.
Liu asked to keep the location
of the site a secret because
he says he's not sure
if the government will crack down one day.
While mining itself isn't illegal,
virtual currency trading
and crypto exchanges are banned in China
because they're seen as risky
to the country's financial system.
In the past few months,
Bitcoin industry insiders have said
that Beijing accused some Chinese miners
of money laundering
and froze their credit cards,
making it difficult for
miners to pay operating costs.
The Chinese government did not respond
to a request for comment.
So to help miners develop their business
despite the risks,
Liu offers loans so miners don't need
to go through Chinese banks.
His company Babel Finance
lends cryptocurrencies
to about 300 miners,
including the owners of this site.
- So that they can purchase more equipment
at a lower cost
and then maintaining the machine itself,
including repairs.
- [Narrator] And Chinese miners
are now facing growing
competition from overseas.
- In the United States,
we have massive infrastructure,
power infrastructure and
building infrastructure
that's already been built out
and we can convert facilities
into large data mining facilities.
- [Narrator] Russell
Cann is an American miner
who scouts the US for abandoned factories
and converts them into mining facilities.
His goal?
Raise cash to develop
industrial-scale mining
in the US where until a few years ago,
most miners ran small DIY operations.
- [Xander] This is my
housing for my computers
so that the heat is vented outside.
- [Narrator] So Core Scientific
has built a team with former executives
from Microsoft and Myspace
and put together an
ambitious business plan.
- We have Ernst & Young
audit the financials.
We have a strong balance sheet.
We check a lot of boxes
for institutional investors
that a Chinese miner does not check.
- [Narrator] The strategy worked.
In the past two years,
the company has raised $95 million
and secured a $20 million loan
to install mining rigs in facilities
including a former denim
factory in North Carolina
and a former carpet factory in Georgia.
Core Scientific's power infrastructure
can handle the latest mining equipment,
which Cann says usually
consumes approximately
100 megawatt hours of
electricity to mine one Bitcoin.
That's the same amount of electricity used
to watch television
continuously for about 98 years.
And tunnels that were once used
to cool the factory are now being used
to keep chips from overheating.
- We've got the ability
to process 200,000
gallons of chilled water
through these pipes to
keep the temperature
in the building down.
- [Narrator] Cann hopes all
this will help him offset
a long-running technological disadvantage.
He was usually about four
months behind his Chinese rivals
when it came to accessing the latest rigs
and the price tag was
sometimes 50% more expensive.
Others are using the
same playbook as Cann,
creating corporations
that attract the support
of institutional investors
who then help fund high-tech mining sites.
Industry insiders and academics
who study mining say
that the US efforts can
be good for the future
of the cryptocurrency
because the original goal of Bitcoin
was to create a currency
that couldn't be controlled by one entity.
- The dream was that we
would reimagine finance
without gatekeepers and what did we get
after 11 years?
We got different kind of intermediaries.
Now mostly nameless, mostly
under the covers in China.
- [Narrator] Emin Gun Sirer
runs a blockchain startup
and is also an associate professor
at Cornell University.
He studies the vulnerabilities
of cryptocurrencies
and says Beijing might
intervene in the market.
- [Emin] This is an enormous issue.
These miners, they could
receive injunctions
that compels them to act in a certain way.
- [Narrator] One request he says
could be to ask miners
to exclude certain people
who want to spend or accept
Bitcoins in the network,
essentially blocking transactions.
This is what Bitcoin
academics call censorship,
similar to how content and accounts
can be blocked on social
media platforms in China.
- The Chinese government would say
that the money at certain addresses
must not move and it
compels the Chinese miners
to not include certain transactions
so they can selectively
sensor certain users
of a blockchain.
- [Narrator] The Chinese
government did not respond
to a request for comment.
Babel Finance says if miners in China
are asked by the government
to intervene in the network,
they would have to comply.
But that would slow down their operations
and eventually diminish their
global processing power.
But US miners aren't
immune to facing scrutiny
from financial regulators at home
that have proposed plans
to hold the industry to
the same standards followed
by traditional financial institutions.
The more immediate resistance
to US miners could come from
local communities concerned
about the environmental
impact of Bitcoin mining.
- Bitcoin mining consumes enormous amounts
of energy so all energy
that goes to miners
is energy that's being directed away
from other more useful uses.
- [Narrator] Cann says nearly
half of the electricity used
by Core Scientific comes
from carbon-free sources.
Because China's miners aren't part
of a corporate structure like in the US,
Liu says that they can operate faster
and spend less on operating costs.
- If you multiply the operational costs,
China still has the advantage.
China will be on the front
of the curve into the future.
- 2021's all about expansion
and we've built infrastructure,
we've built the software,
we've built the team
to be a long-term player in this market.
(upbeat music)